As you may know, the American right wing has made
a big bet on cultural issues in the United States
for the last many years, increasingly so, as I
talked about in a segment before our recent break.
And part of this has been noticeable in
the total lack of policy discussion by
the Republican Party. It's basically a playbook
of called the left socialists and communists.
Oppose everything Democrats want to do and try to
win on that platform, and sometimes it works and
sometimes it doesn't work quite so well. The other
part, of course, is waging war on issues like
council culture, which we've talked about now
must be a dozen times. And as a quick cliff note,
remember that Donald Trump campaigned on
being against council culture. His cronies,
fellow Republicans have endlessly ranted
about being against suppression of speech,
against regulation of businesses, against
all of it. We knew it was always a ruse.
We knew it was always a way to hype people up
in order to get them activated, get donations
out of them. From the left is evil, authoritarian
suppressors of speech. And it's come full circle.
Now, Donald Trump and Republicans, after months of
denouncing supposed council culture on the left,
are demanding boycotts of countless organizations
and companies because they don't like the speech
being expressed by those companies. It's hard
to pinpoint exactly where this fiasco started,
but a big part of it was voter suppression bills
in a number of states, including notably Georgia.
Georgia passed a bill that would significantly
restrict voting and make it harder to vote.
One organization that spoke out that's speech
about the bill was Major League Baseball. Major
League Baseball was scheduled to have their
All-Star game in Georgia. And I believe they're
a draft as well. They've pulled it because
of the Georgia bill. This is not trivial.
The tourism industry experts believe that
pulling the all star game will cost Georgia about
one hundred million dollars. Now, there is a real
argument. There's a good faith argument to be had
about whether Major League Baseball and
others who are now saying Boycott Georgia
are actually hurting the people who pass the bill
versus hurting people who just work at all sorts
of businesses that would benefit from having the
all star game there. That's a fair debate that I
totally respect that debate. But Donald Trump
has come out and said boycott everyone who is
participating in the boycotts or even speaking
out against the Georgia bill and other bills.
Trump delivering his delusional Easter message,
which we are going to look at, saying for years
the radical left Democrats have played dirty
by boycotting products when anything from that
company is done or stated in any way that offends
them. Now they are going big time with WOAK,
cancel culture and our sacred elections. It is
finally time for Republicans and conservatives
to fight back. We have more people than they do by
far. Look at this boycott. Major League Baseball,
Coca-Cola, Delta Airlines, JPMorgan Chase, Viacom,
CBS, Citigroup, Cisco, UPS and Merck. Don't go
back to their products until they relent. We can
play the game better than them. Trump saying we
can out cancel the cancel culture people. They
didn't even get approval of state legislatures,
which is mandated under the US Constitution.
And then he throws and they rigged and stole
our twenty twenty presidential election, which
we won by a landslide. And then on top of that
boycott and scare companies into submission, never
submit, never give up, says Trump. The radical
left will destroy our country. If we let them, we
will not become a socialist nation. I don't know
what that has to do with anything. And then Trump
saying, Happy, Happy Easter. This is the council
culture Trump claims to be against. This is Donald
Trump, a former president, no less saying cancel
these companies because they have the wrong
opinion by which he means an opinion Trump
doesn't like. Now, as a total side note. This is
just from my experience over the vacation week,
Trump saying Boycott Delta. I hope his followers
do. I just flew last week fully vaccinated,
of course, with a mask, with a test negative test.
Doctors were shocked by how well I did on my test
the number of right wingers on my flights who
just insisted on taking their masks off at every
opportunity continually. Oops, I forgot to put my
mask back on after having one sip of my water. I
believe the skies would be much safer if Trump
boycotted flying altogether for the time being.
Have at it. OK, that rant aside, one of the things
I really like about the Joe Biden presidency so
far is that Joe Biden isn't a radically and
hyperbolically weighing in on all of these
issues. Some people are saying boycott. Others
are saying don't. OK, Joe Biden said he would
support moving the all star game out of Georgia
over the law. And that's it. He's busy governing.
He's busy getting four million shots, multiple
days in a row into the arms of people, which we
will talk about tomorrow. Let others decide what
to do and who to boycott. But the irony of Trump
supposedly against council culture, making himself
the consoler in chief is really stunning. And this
is the case with everything. We've exposed this
for a decade on the show. They're against deficit
increases until their guy is in office and
wants to go to war, give tax cuts for the rich.
They're against canceling things unless
it's them doing the canceling and on and on.
I won't go through a dozen examples
because we've done it so many times before.
Their stated principles mean nothing when
circumstances change. And we will have
more coverage of this on our Instagram page.
Find us at David Pakman show on Instagram and
find pictures from our spring break. You
will see how safely I was living spring break
on my Instagram at David Pakman. By the
way, about a hundred people unfollowed me
on Instagram when I posted a picture of myself at
a beach pointing out that I was fully vaccinated
and a bunch of people saying, Why aren't you
wearing a mask? I'm by myself on a beach. Why?
Why would I be wearing a mask? But you know what?
That's their right. I'm not nobody's canceling
anybody. It's a beautiful thing. Anyway, David
Pakman on Instagram. Quick break. Back after this.